[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
players from nine nations converge in
st. Louis as US chess champs calm
presents the second annual summer chess
classic hello and welcome back to round
five of the summer chess classic here in
st. Louis today of course is round five
meaning it's the last round before the
rest day starting tomorrow so probably
gonna see some fatigue from the players
but maybe some will get a second win
just knowing that tomorrow is their
glorious day off for rest and maybe some
preparation going into the second half
let's take a look well first of all my
name is Caleb Ben B and this is GM
jessie cry and we will be your host for
today as we have been for the past four
days and why don't we just take a look
right at the standings in group a well
we can get the standings in a second
story is Jeffrey Zhang and David Howell
leading group a going into today which
players and has impressed you more
throughout this tournament Jessie
impressive I would say I was thinking
about this earlier today I think Jeffrey
is the best calculator of the entire
tournament and I've just seen him
analyze some I guess I know as well that
he's at one of these puzzle rush freaks
that he can do it you can do it open but
he's made some funny moves positionally
I thought in this game coming out from
an opening that was pretty good maybe we
will just start with this game and then
we'll jump to the standing show we can
just jump into the game so it was what
are these these things that I'm really
interested with we're gonna get Howell
someday in here and talk to him about it
you know so Jeffrey plays e4 and how
we'll just starts thinking just like
deep philosophical thoughts about what
to do and pondering the eternal question
well how do you respond
did the same thing when he played salmon
around 1:00 and then ended up choosing
the Berlin and here he chooses the
Petrov and I'm not exactly sure but I
think Jeffrey was encouraged to do this
because he felt maybe like black didn't
know becoming ending and this is an
opening line that saw playing the World
Championship
that's right right that's right and I
think it's I think it's very clever
the idea is you threatened e5 Knight d5
and then you play f3 it might look kind
of weird at first but your deep own kind
of wants to go to d4 so you don't really
want to play d3 right and the King I
think wants to go to f2 though
apparently I have a disagreement with
Jeffrey on that score because he does
not move the kingdom to and it's funny
because there's some similarities with
yesterday's game which fr8 had against
daro
where he pad c6 and did not play king c7
and here he is not flaking of two but I
thought he got a nice opening advantage
here and I think if white plays just
King f2 he's kind of just a little bit
better of a position especially because
this Knight is dominated by the pawn and
he's got a little bit of opening and a
development advantage too but he plays
this move which i think is controversial
just because there's no need yet to be
pushing all your stuff Bishop d6 and now
another controversial move Knight c3
this one controversial because the
knight is not clear that the knight
wants to go there in particular if you
were gonna kick this guy then maybe you
wanted at least the option of throwing
the pawn to c4 to fight for the d5
square but now that's gone
and this Knight is going to have to work
to find
to home it's hard like moving into
domination maybe was a question of do
you want to block the sea pond or do you
want to block the dark-squared bishop
right this option at least lets Jeffery
develop his dark squared bishop could
have also said hey let's play King F 2
because cry told me that's what I was
doing you know and this would have left
way more options at the table but again
like what was the rush in playing g4 in
the last move yeah they say mistakes
come in pairs and so this might be an
example of that I don't I didn't by the
way I didn't look on the computer
anything that's just my teeth that those
two moves were a little bit funny blacks
next move definitely is a star move and
he plays h5 and all of a sudden the
light squares are going to become weak
because g5 is forced and whites blacks
gonna lose a little bit of time but one
of the genius things about this is not
only to regain the square but since the
knight on f6 was dominated it makes
sense to begin some plan where you have
to move him anyway right so Knight g8
castles a little bit weird and I wanted
to put him on F 297 and rook e1 and here
I felt black was definitely better but
maybe the next move let white a little
bit off the hook so I think for example
just if you just played 97 and f8 and
concentrate on these beautiful light
squares that you've won looks like an
advantage especially because this guy's
so terrible now yeah maybe Geoffrey was
thinking he could go to a 4 and then put
that night on c5 maybe I don't know it
94 you're dominated with b6 as well I
guess so anyways the problem with Bishop
f5 is not immediately apparent but it's
it is that after this trade happens
Bishop f4 is gonna come and it's gonna
make it difficult for the black King to
move right so we get 97 Bishop f4 and
now I think white is close to equality
because the King yeah
it would love to hang out there but it's
got some issues now hmm and King f8 is a
little bit sad because that was really
the square I wanted my knight to go too
right
okay so Jeffry says all right I'll fix
the night all right I'll fix my pawn
all right I'll trade this terrible thing
and in this position I I don't know it
feels roughly equal to me yeah yeah I
think I would agree you know the four
versus four on the Queen side and three
versus three on the Kings side with only
Knights and rooks it doesn't look like a
lot right and I think a big miss chance
for how this this position I thought was
very nice with g5 and in a way I feel
like it's a Berlin players thought if
the lights were because that you know in
the Berlin you you coax him to play e5
to get the f5 Square and here we hope
stand play g5 to get the f5 Square
so we'll keep our eye on that but I
guess that's gonna be a draw so maybe
now we can look at the stand yeah let's
take a look and see where everybody
stands in Group A so of course Geoffrey
Zhang and David Howell are tied at the
top these two players are both plus one
on the tournament and they face each
other today and what looks like an equal
position following them close behind is
Darius sweets and Gawain Jones and
rounding out Group A but still white
within striking distance is Liam Lee and
Sam Shanklin two of the top seeds coming
into the tournament right and let's
actually go ahead and take a look at
Group B now Group E used to just be
Surya Ganguly up at the top but he's had
a slow couple last rounds with two draws
and Gregori Oberon has actually caught
him up at the top and now I want to ask
you again
which of these players do you have your
eye on who's your pick to pull ahead in
this event well I think Ganguly has been
playing I very impressed with his play
and Oprah and I I'm trying to get a read
on the guy he plays you know Knight f3
g3 Bishop g2 and he kind of leaves like
a sneaky player and honestly you know in
terms of just raw talent and like hope
Savion has always been there this is and
that's since I met the kid in 2012 you
know I've always thought that guy was
coming up and like Geoffrey Jean he's
you know struggling to break into 2700
and it is brutally hard brutally hard
start maybe with Sam's game even there
sure I guess we could jump into saying
okay let's go to see first sure yeah
first let's see how the C group is
standing today so archers Knights sons
has pulled ahead of the crowd with three
points however he is followed closely
behind by four players in the field all
tied for second place and there are
quite a number of players hoping to
strike at the top and today I think is
gonna be the the chance to do that they
kind of need to have somebody pull ahead
of the root of the other three in order
to give archers a little bit of a
challenge for the top place and rounding
out Group C is of course Christian
shrila and before we jump into the games
let's take a quick look at the
tournament format and see what kind of
format these players are playing in
there are three six player double round
robins which means in each of the three
groups everybody plays all of the
opponents twice in the time control for
these games is 90 minutes for the first
40 moves with 30 minutes sudden-death
for the remainder of the game they are
given a 30-second increment from move
one and there's a 30 move draw rule in
effect so no draws before move 30 and
the schedule for the event is quite
important here today because it is the
last day before the rest day so tomorrow
the players get a day off the
commentators get a day off and will come
back refreshed and ready for more
exciting chess on Monday you can join us
here on YouTube as for the broadcast you
can chat along with us we're keeping an
eye on that see Patrick Daly in there
he's a he's a regular I think on these
broadcasts you can join us on Twitter
using the hashtag summer chess classic
and you can follow the games for
yourself online on us chess chance comm
and now let's take a look at the
pairings for group B since we already
kind of took a look at what's going on a
group a so Daniel Friedman and Havana's
kuboos Ian have actually drawn their
game already at the day today I know has
been playing very very solidly this
tournament it's tough to score a point
off him and he continues that trend
today
Sam Sabean is paired against Ibaka
Malenko and then our key matchup in
Group E is between Rory Oberon and Surya
Ganguly the two leaders are squaring off
today and Group B so let's go ahead and
take a look at that game and see how how
they're faring yeah this has been an
interesting game I I have felt for the
last 20 moves or so that I thought
Ganguly was better and the problem that
plagues white has been plaguing whites
it's still there for him which is that
this Bishop has been a little bit
awkward in terms of what to do with the
guy and the Queen is penetrated however
there's some obvious thoughts for white
to if if this Bishop can never get
active and it's also a question of like
are these pawns ever going to become
weak so let's maybe take a look let's
look at ochre in style right he's been
doing this all the time and you know I
think originally back in the day when
people played g3 and Bishop g2 they did
so with the thought of like oh I just
want to get an on theoretical game and I
want to play but actually now Oberon is
very booked up on all the different like
setups that black can play so it's not
actually a you know getting yourself out
of Dodge moment with the theory but we
get this and I would say I guess let's
say c4 is the main move but I think
Ganguly was at least making him wonder
if on c4 he was gonna take DC that was a
question he was throwing out right now
after b3 I like a lot what Ganguly does
he plays a5 and to me this is kind of a
classic positional notion I could maybe
I'll just go back and
there was a famous game get it a little
bit yeah there's a famous game which
went like this in the bot fennec tall
match it went I might get the move order
a little bit wrong but it's all the same
so c4 c6 b 3 94 d4 and this is a
fascinating position where black has a
lot of different options you can imagine
you know of course you can Castle first
but then there's gonna be things like 97
f6 Bishop f5 but when you start looking
at those minor piece movements it's not
necessarily clear that they know yet
where they want to go okay okay so a
great plan is probably castles first
let's say castles Bishop b2 and now a5
and the cool point is you know we don't
know yet what White's gonna do against
our a pawn but what we're gonna say is
you know first of all my bishop will be
developed if my rook is developed and
we're just gonna wait a little bit with
the night right so that's kind of what
happens here in this game with a5 a4 and
yeah I like I like black
yeah just finding a lot of counter play
on the open a fight and this is a notice
standard operand move he's just gonna
take it easy I just gonna take it easy
black says okay I'll put my Queen over
here on a5 I thought he was a little bit
better so right because the bishop
because the a file mm-hmm and here we're
starting to get the dynamic we're gonna
see in the game where black is gonna say
that the double claws aren't that big of
a deal and that the bishop on a1 is
terror
Queen a - maybe there's other moves that
I have a feeling if we ask Ganguly that
might be one of the moves he has maybe
regrets about but this is all pretty
normal in and equal time it's working so
we'll pay attention to this game huge
for the standings and also just a really
interesting positional struggle I assume
black is considering 95 now and amongst
other things and if black is gonna claim
he's better he needs to figure this guy
out and yes he can't give white much
time because if white gets time to do
things like g5 in Queens u4 then we will
have some grief yeah it's almost like
maybe the double puns aren't so much
weak in themselves but they're kind of
weak in blacks King as well right so
there's gonna be some some danger there
maybe that's look at what happens you're
85 it should be one queen 83 Bishop d2
knight of seven keeping an eye on that
chief I swear yeah and right you know
really making a claim that the b-pawn
yeah the white is tied down to the B
pond and but in order to really make
progress blacks gonna have to do
something like five I don't know but
once he does that though then you know
the cat is out of the bag and it's go
time and and maybe actually a move for
white is maybe thing about now is f4
hoping to break open the light squares
with f5
absolutely so while I like the gang
Ghoulies position before for sure now
I'm not I don't know who's better now
yeah there's some ideas for both sides I
guess it's really a question of can
operon make this Bishop a genius or not
I think f4 looks real strong I don't
know
you know maybe 96 but still f5 it's
trying to hold on but
I'm not convinced it's I have feeling
they they're probably both already
seeing this variation and then maybe
something like snip hmm and if we take
it all off it's not that special okay
like being here but this guy's still
miserable like still left or white still
left that Bishop yeah yeah well okay you
want to take a look at what's going on
in the C group sure actually before we
leave that lets go
Samuels game real quick Samuels had a
really interesting position I'm sure
both sides have made mistakes or
inaccuracy is whatever you want to call
it but this is another game this is
where I'm up there and I'm like is
Kovalenko not coming or something cuz
there's no movement or maybe the board's
frozen but no he thought for I don't
know 20 minutes after E for Wow Sam
doesn't usually play E for and so he's
just dislike I'm gonna tank on this one
he eventually plays e6 which i think is
what he normally does and Sam also plays
the French so ice maybe that was part of
the thinking and Kovalenko like I don't
want to face it
so I'm gonna guess that Kovalenko it in
his mind when he made this decision
decided to go for this following
sidelines I'm gonna call it a sideline
here with Queen a forth and the idea is
just to be annoying to stop a four and
at some point maybe shut it all down
with c4 white as many moves here Queen
g4 is the most aggressive I think I
might have even been at this club
Lenderman was black and played King f8
against Fabi but g6 is the other option
and g6 you know there's both both moves
King f8 and g6 have drawbacks and g6 of
course the problem is h4 it gives white
a hook and this is a very violent game
because what white is saying is I'll let
you take the
on and although the point itself isn't
that big of a deal what's really nice
for black is that he gets to go back to
help defend the King so night c6h5 Queen
c2 Knight f3 and that move surprised me
at first but I've it's growing on me
okay it's grown on me I think there are
other things black could have done too
as a French player I never really want
to do that move but what its gonna say
is by keeping your bishop off of this
point I'm gonna be able to easily hold
this thing here was it I think this was
right here White's big choice he could
he could have played snip even that
endgame I think isn't very nice for what
he could you know even play that or of
course that's the most very natural what
he did looked like let's call it the
standard white attacking move but check
out what black found a great plan in
response Bishop d7 rook h3 and here's
here's a real star move I thought this
was genius h6 wow this is the kind of
thing I get excited about so when you
play g6 part of the problem when you
play g6 is you've weakened squares like
g5 and h6 does two things that of course
stops the night and it gives your queen
this nice retreat square stops the night
and the bishop because both of those
pieces wanted to invade the dark squares
so I thought age six was genius rook g3
queen h7 and now Bishop d1 and I think
this is blacks big question for himself
he plays kind of a strange move here
with rook f8
my sense is just just intuitively is
that 97 is gonna be better for black do
I know that for sure no but I just I
feel like he feels it because white has
to play like rook c1 then Bishop c2 and
I'm ready to play rook g8 and Knight a5
and some days I might even play Queen e4
anyways rook f8 maybe ya enter I think
he may be underestimated this move like
he's because it does look weird night h4
he's thinking that he wants I'm guessing
he wanted to play either f6 or f5 but
now the knight is hitting this square
plus when this Knight comes out which I
guess it kind of has to now because we
are threatening Knight g6 now then I as
a job as well is it he's stopping this
so in so no work I think it looks like
oh maybe we shouldn't have even done
that well you can still try to play
something like f6 or f5 right it's
difficult okay because you unless you
win the pawn you know this is you you
gotta be real careful about opening
those dark squares yeah rook c19 f5 and
we get this position and I think maybe
it's roughly equal or something but this
is very dangerous for black guy
I've suffered a lot in the French and
the bummer here is really still the dark
squares can black and white invade and
is this Queen like not going to be able
to help her man yeah over there so Queen
h4 and now he goes for it with snip he
had other things to do but he did that
one snip snip snip and very hard
position for me to evaluate but the
claim is simple the claim is that we got
our pawn back and that our bishop is
better than your knight this one
is better than this night and this
bishop is better than this bishop so is
the problem for white is Gaddy activate
his rook it looks hard it's hard
activate the rook if he can find a way
to activate the rook here then then I'll
believe in white but it looks like
oposition black has something kind of
like a fortress now alright okay
beautiful right and let us actually go
now to the secret level sleep and see
how they are faring Christian trill is
paired against around huh Cobian
Gordievsky drew his game against Group C
leader hard tears naik Suns so maybe
that left the door open for one of those
other three followers to catch up and
the game we're gonna keep our eye on is
the game between Brandon Jacobsen and el
Shawn Murad II Abadi both of these
players on two out of four and hoping to
score a win today to make it to the top
Brandon himself has actually led Group C
before and Al Shean has had some chances
in his games but hasn't been able to
quite pull it off so let's see what's
going on with both of these players in
round five yeah boy genius is really
playing a great game so far and right if
he wins this game he'll catch snakes ons
and here let's start with this position
when I define you know we're just they
did their standard efore a five dance
right and they reach this position and
to me black can't be that bad here it's
just hard for me to believe he's in any
kind of real trouble because either work
on a one's funny and yadda yadda but
white is holding like some daggers over
blacks head in particular like is Bishop
h6 a threat and so that's one of the
things he's got to figure out right now
and I guess he didn't because what
happened was
snip-snip Knight f8 and then Brandon
immediately
damn Wow there it is and it wasn't
immediately obvious to me what the idea
is but it's pretty clear-cut when you
look at it so snip snip let's say one of
these night stage 7
of course this night was hanging right
mm-hmm so night g5 in the threat which
isn't immediately obvious and maybe else
Shawn missed is that we're gonna play
night h7 let's say for example Edie
9 8 7 night h7 f 6 and if that's serious
Griffin we got some a lot of threats
there and this kind of n I wouldn't even
call in them game that's just gonna be
lost because you're Kingston you're
gonna get made so that was a beautiful
shot and you know one thing I'll say
about these openings is let's just take
this position for example that the slow
piano it's you know it's a funny thing
it's an equal but if you're an attacking
player like a lot of these e4 people are
you can play this position with an
attack in your soul even though it might
not feel like there's an attack
immediately but you have to be patient
and create moves like Knight f5 where
you know black is under pressure and
they're having I guess there had to have
been something else than what he did but
after this BAM
and so when else Shawn played this it
felt a little bit like I'm resigning
like blacks resigning because the
problem is it's ok yes I'm up a pawn and
yes I have the two bishops now but like
this night I don't know what he wants
yeah that's difficult the pun enough
I've just actually taking some very
important squares away from that and I
don't yeah the knight like where is he
ever gonna go yeah
Oh Shawn makes a threat that looks kind
of like me and then rook g1 wreck h1 and
now he's gonna this is you know he's
going in desperation mode now I will say
these positions aren't just totally easy
to win you still have to have a lot of
skill and Jacobson has six minutes left
by the way I want to say Brandon you
made fun of me for going too slow when
we played bughouse together but every
game I see you you're in time pressure
so you better you better hurry it up
so far he's picked up the pace when it
counts though yeah I mean he the kid is
one of these people that can move
instantly this is hey I like the way L
shine at least is trying to hold on to
this thing the night on f8 that the the
guy who was on h7 at least has an idea
now of doing something like that so the
game isn't actually over and I think um
you know you go back to this position I
feel like that's got to be totally over
but but maybe now you need to start
thinking of other things okay this is
what I don't know Shem let me just say
for my chess point of view all right I
don't understand why you would tell
yourself here that you want to start
running the King to the Queen side
you've got all those pawns in front of
your king dude you who could you're the
master of that situation
so like Knight f1 yeah anyone looks very
natural but just for my point of view I
I know I like to when I have a pawn
majority like this against my opponents
King it's natural to me to want to move
those even four farther forward and
start generating some threats but he
needs to first fix his Bros over here
yeah we're doing all this stuff and look
like no I don't like this no Glen Oh
Brandon no bueno so now yeah we'll keep
our eyes on it I think anything's
possible and el Shawn that with B 5 is
simply saying you know what if you want
to go to the Queen side we can open up
that part of the board - yeah so we got
everything going on there let's look at
Christians game sure the other game in
Group C is still going on sure Ella also
known as the count and
here was a funny thing to wear yeah
Christian plays he's been a big advocate
for years of playing the groom felled so
he's now facing the groom felled and
plays this sideline black plays c5 and
instantly the count goes like this
and Cobian started tanking here and the
weird thing was that in this position I
feel like the count didn't know quite
what to do I thought the next counts
next move is very provocative I think
you could do things like rook c3 or rook
c1 and it's mostly I don't know equal or
something like that but with interesting
play but the count
oh now the rook is not going to come
back easily it's not a solid square but
it's certainly making more threats
minute.what on the C file yeah but he
needs to castle before he starts making
this and here black had a number of
interesting moves he ended up playing h6
but I thought also very tempting was
just castles Bishop d7 looked good
and I think the idea the idea of age six
was that after this guy let me put it
this way I think what he was thinking of
his Bishop d7 rook takes and now you
can't leave the bishop yet so you're
gonna have to do something like age six
now should you maybe be worried about
the exchange sacrifice maybe maybe you
should be worried about so I think
that's what motivates this h6 move but
that gives Christian the eye at least
the chance a kind of sort of bail out
with this move does it get him out of
Dodge completely I don't think so but
let's look at what happened Knight d4
rook c5 castles Queen a3 Queen d2 a5
Bishop b2 Queen a2 or we're doing this
big dance here right yeah
and black is up upon obviously well it
looks it looks nice looks nice yeah the
problem is that the bishop on g7 isn't
in the game so do I think Akopian is
better he is but I don't but it's not
over yet it's not over yet yeah
so actually we got a solution we got
night c2 on the board check to the
miserable King have a seat eight night
so night c2 you didn't have to be played
it was a very forcing move and yeah
black is obviously that helps black gain
some time right with the King on f1 it's
going to be a little bit harder to get
the rock on h1 into the game you're
gonna lose some time dude okay but
you've got to deal with your knight
right it looks real bad for the count
here it just looks real bad because if
nothing else I can play Bishop a4 if I
need to and the counts got two minutes
well let's go back up let's go back
upstairs yeah Group a definitely a lot
of action going on so Geoffrey it's
looking pretty draws I'd say you know I
watched Geoffrey analyze this game with
Daria sterday he probably should well I
he was either lost or very close to lost
in that game and I got a feel for how
much he likes to calculate in the
endgame so that was kind of interesting
and here I think it's roughly equal but
you know Geoffrey is not going to stop
playing and the dream anyway is to say
something like well on rook f4 you have
to worry about this square in this
square mm-hmm is it a little bit of
something-something
maybe yeah probably I mean but I'm sure
would would be happy with the draw here
and I think Wyatt is the only one who
kind of wants to keep playing okay how
will go fight
one game we didn't talk about was this
incredible struggle with Gawain and LEM
and it was a very strange position from
the start and it's it's it's remained
strange it's strange to me just some
powerful bishops go through this thing
c3 is the I'm gonna say that c3 is the
old way to play against with the Oh bleh
to play the Rosalina d4 d5 II 594 and
this is I think the reason why it's
considered a bummer is that the knight
gets on e4 and it's looking almost like
you've got a great French now there
should be three snip-snip I thought I
this just shows what I know I thought
black was just beautiful here Wayne c1
and black had a number of reasonable
moves here I was watching and I was like
why not just rook behavior
yeah that pun but okay f6 Knight c3 and
this is a really provocative move Bishop
e6 it's it's the kind oh you do want to
be careful about it because you're
setting yourself up for all this stuff
so it doesn't work because we're hitting
the night but still yeah you're making
me nervous
danger yeah me nervous so white took and
I wanted him to play EF but I think the
problem is maybe then I can let me
actually ask that question so on EF do I
have a favorable version of this because
the F file is closed
maybe I do maybe I do and here in
addition to d5 I can consider 92 but but
d5 here looks better than yeah normal
the danger is opening up that diagonal
for the dark square bishop maybe but I
mean even this position looks good yeah
cuz I'm coming with my c4 so that's why
Bishop f6 now 95 rook a c8 and I like
this is old-school by the way this Queen
c3 this is just the dark square grip
that they teach you in your first
wrestling class right where we're
touching all these squares and we're
saying yeah that the grip is on the dark
squares and this Bishop now has really
turned into a beautiful piece on this
diagonal but also of course here it's
protecting really whites only weak point
putting that bishop on e6 has kind of
become like a factory of threats for
white every turn you can renew this
threat and improve his pieces that's
right yeah
a5 I've lost track of the tactics what
if I if you play d5 the night will end
up falling okay
like Queen b8 Queen b8 okay taking
advantage of the pen these guys are
crazy right
rook AC 158 and it's gonna get crazier
so this next move I'm sure he did with
some calculate he definitely did some
crazy calculation but it's it's really
positional in nature it's the dark
square squeeze that I mentioned before
yeah let's just actually pay pay homage
to these moves Queen c1 dark square
Queen c3 dark square Queen c5 dark
square
I got wasted one time my young Elvis
doing this kind of thing to me and I to
me it was just an epiphany that you
could play chess like that Wow
so here we go check this out you know
good positional ideas need tactics
behind them and I'm pretty sure that
white had the following figured out when
he did this queen bee to knight c6 rook
d6 and this is kind of a tactics trainer
moment here d5
yeah dangerous stuff I don't I don't
trust it for black so the point is is
that if you take this guy well
unfortunately then your rooks hanging
after 97 and if you play rook takes then
again 97 and you're king it's your king
that's got the grief your life so really
nice tactic and he misty I I'm pretty
sure he let Liam miss some of this year
because now he really started to tank
and of course when you take on b2 that's
kind of what you're thinking about is
look well can he take on c6 so do you
find I guess you have to move the bishop
he moves the king who's the king so that
now 97 isn't a check okay so go incest
alright I'll renew the threat on e7 and
that looks pretty Evil Queen a6 really
nice play now I'm touching the rook on
c8
the one oh man oh this is really good
look at this tactic Queen a two night
before oh yeah that's that's the
backwards moves are the ones that are so
hard to see hurts we you know okay so
that the rook is hit and the bishop on
e6 a great deal of finesse coming out of
here just white seems to be touching all
of the all of the sensitive points Wow
and look at it so when the rook comes
here then there's this fork so right we
we move and then we snip it
look at this guy Wow we got to get to
get that guy in here yes
get that guy in here effing Illya him an
impressive sequence of news there so I'm
assuming this is toast now if Bishop be
one Queen takes d7 black needs black
needs some kind of miracle now because
well Burnett let's not even threading
anything unfortunately for the guy and
the black king is weaker it's hard to
imagine that the eight pawns gonna do
something here so the attack is gonna
bit too far away maybe also just with
the rooks yeah I guess we should say
that White's main goal I think is trade
both these bishops and a rook and then
we'll get full active that's access to
the king if black manages to trade the
Queen's then maybe he's got a shot at
holding this position even though I
don't know even that looks looks tough
okay maybe Joey and Jones threatening to
join the leaders yeah if Geoffrey's game
ends peacefully all right Sam yeah Sam
Shane Glen against area Suites what is
done for us in group a so this has been
a real exciting struggle and wow maybe
Sam is pressing a little bit here one
thing he did so so sphere so they did a
little Catalan dance mm-hmm 97 d4 Bishop
b4 and I have done flavors of this move
with my BT to myself it is a strange
move usually it goes like this
Bishop g2 let excuse me you would
normally you have to play you'd play d4
first right so d4 depending on the move
water check to the misérable King and
now
bTW - and who think about this move is I
think it's technically unsound because
of DC how would it go DC Bishop g2 c3
actually I won't call it unsound I'll
just say that you have compensation for
the material that you've lost okay but
the problem that I couldn't figure out
is when you do it like Sam does it here
even if he doesn't take the pawn on c4
this is your night really that well
placed on d2 because the whole idea with
his bishop before is to say that the
bishop on d2 is misplaced right right
that's the idea and then you go back and
then we do a little dance and then the
bishop doesn't know what it's listen to
in life so anyways we got this position
black has many different moves here c6
will call c6 the most standard level
snip-snip 95 Bishop b7 queen a for a fun
so on the surface it looks like mayhem
but it looks on the surface to like
maybe blacks out of it
why NASA Bishop hard to say if that's
important Queen c4 Bishop d2 work day
for Queen b3 that was the first exact
move well it's not the only exactly
systems play but that's a very exact way
to try to play for the advantage now
with rook AC one being definitely the c7
pawn being the weak point in blacks
campaign right so Dario says I'm gonna
snip and I'm gonna try to trade
everything off I would have been tempted
by rook aid
Sam says no we're gonna fight and this
is a very combative move because you're
saying that black can play rook a to at
some point I was always told about
backwards pawns is that you need major
pieces to really put pressure on them
especially on a half-open file so I
think black was trying to trade some
major pieces but you know white keeps on
the rook to put that pressure but at the
expense of some counter play right so
now black can play something like like
you said rook a to getting his own ideas
involved right and here was a question -
I'm I'm assuming c5 runs into some kind
of DC and b4 thing that's my assumption
okay so c6 now another nice move Bishop
h3 this prevents then f6 Knight from
moving which is a big deal because it
wanted to go here and it makes things I
think like on rook a to now we can start
thinking about this and if King f8 we
can start really thinking about
and all of a sudden it's like oh no so
several very nice endgame moves here
from Sam h6 Bishop b4 a beautiful move
and now if you play rook a - you better
wonder about they should be three
careful sealing the box so you go to
Ricky a now we'll take the a file mmm as
a beautiful endgame
rook a Stefan's threatened so he gets
out of the way with Bishop c6 be for
rook a seven big complications but I
guess we're gonna say White's at least a
little bit better yeah Sam you're
playing well BAM
right so Sam has played a great game and
here we're gonna have to say he has both
the pawn and the compensation right he's
got the better bishops he's got the rook
the bishop on before the unopposed
Bishop hits one so there's no dastardly
checks yeah this is a bummer for blacks
so good this is the kind of play that
one Sam the US Championship mm-hmm and
they got him over 2,700 in the first
place just very ruthless calculation
energy you know some creativity some
precise moves that as as well kind of
putting his pieces on just the right
square to control the important squares
and kind of limit blacks truck
especially from getting into position I
did want to mention you know games are
really heating up and grupe it looks
like a lot of action going on there and
before we leave Sam let's just note this
that rook c7 I was wondering like what
is it if nothing else we can play Brooks
e8
and just and all of the counter play Wow
so that's a problem and if you leave the
back rank with rookie - you better
wonder about Bishop g6 yeah definite
mating that's so beautiful play well
we'll check in with that soon which game
would you like to see first - group B
let's take a look at Sam 7 cuz I think
you did a really nice job of activating
not his rook but and set his King to
make some more threats okay we had this
position rook F 151 they should see -
right we're gonna talk to the f5 1v1
forces him to do this which he really
doesn't want to do it takes away any B
for ideas
now that's deeper t1 I don't know maybe
just the classical idea of taking away
scores from the night no matter what
happens right taking away that D 2
square there just controls all of the
nights forward hops I think actually the
idea is that if you play Bishop f4 you
want to make sure be Fortis yeah so that
as well taking away the Knights pressure
on undie for King bees basics I don't
know what that moved us White has the
luxury if ya just move that forward a
little bit that's fine
taking some time and now he comes up and
it's still the same question yeah can
white activate the rook at the moment it
looks very difficult to do it but so I
guess I have some questions
oh yeah what if we play rook at fun
mm-hm and then maybe not immediately
some idea with with g4 to get the rip in
the game I'm sure he's looking but black
yeah I don't know how it works here but
but yeah that's what we have to look at
okay Rick f1 is actually on the board it
looks like was just playing and black is
gonna have to sit and you know one way
to talk about this is when black that I
thought black had a great position and
it was with this decision here he begins
the kind of descent to what we get now
right where then he plays you know
Knight g7 Knight f5 when we get this
structure which is just unpleasant
and in particular the knight on v3 now
isn't really working
yeah it's a little out of a game way on
the Queen side I had one more idea so
what happens after Bishop d1 is there
any way for the White King to make some
inroads
his bishop d1 forces the rook off of h5
and then maybe the King can come in to
to g5 it's a thought and then there's
gonna be some kind of check on the G
file yeah and maybe just King age four
and then I want to set up with the same
kind of idea I want to put my bishop on
the c2 have two attackers on f5 and
maybe with the King's help I can keep
the rook from actually coming to the
defense yeah you could totally think
about it
the great news is this guy isn't helping
and black maybe should start thinking
right now about bringing the guy back
Knight a5 to c6 maybe then the e7 and
that looks like a nice defensive try
given enough time well right and why
it's gonna need time to crack this this
business mm-hmm so but check it out once
you go Knight a5 c6 then you have to
worry about rook b1
yeah can't stray too far away so there's
a good massage going on here maybe if
I'm black I'd like to trade the places
of not exactly of my king and my knight
I want my King to defend my be pawn yeah
you could put your King here you'd be
winning well I'm not quite that
ambitious but maybe if I put my king on
some place like c6 and I got my Knight
to e7 if I could achieve that oh I'd be
quite happy yes something like that as
it is that King can't really help that
up on the Knights Knights terrible I
feel like that could be one of the
things we ended up talking about too is
like that the knight b3 looked looked
like the angry thing to do in a V you
regretted a little bit so what's going
on in the game between the leaders in
this section alright quite a bit has has
changed since we last took a look oh man
all right let's look so we had 9 f7 and
I was talking about hf4 Oakland does a
similar idea which is h4 just to open up
that beautiful Bishop looking from here
to the current position it's just like
all the pawns exploded
right and taking off and we said we said
that if I've had two to come yet h5g
thought oh gee
she's movies so I think Angola is gonna
be upset with this position hmm you know
there's all kinds of stuff happening and
we're in deep really good time pressure
here yeah for the moment white is is
just up a clear pond it looks like and
and I think the drama was we needed to
stop Queenie six you're absolutely so
let's think about this I would say the
problem is less the porn and more that
King right I think the good news is
black still does have a little bit of
freedom of movement right the Queen but
can come back to f7 the rook is
available to jump in somewhere maybe to
c6
start shaking things up not right away
with Queenie a check on the board but I
just want to start with something like
Queen f7 and ask why how do you continue
this attack if I bring my pieces back
let's say queen of 702 simple 84 and
then this Rick c6 move I like it a lot
to set up this rook on the sixth ranked
defending against any g6 ideas let's
just say calmly do that sure you're more
than welcome to and now for my next
trick I want to pass because I can't
improve my pieces it's right right it's
very rough and and d5 is coming right
and this looks like maybe it could be
problematic well also my rook is going
to come yeah yeah I don't like it that
you know there's if you could get you
know maybe Queen f7 is certainly a
natural move but right you you might
want a little bit more violence and in
fact that's what it does I like this for
like us move a lot that black just
played the threat of
actual I'm assuming well if nothing else
he's got Queenie for its Queenie four
there might be Bishop f4 rerouting the
Bishop Bishop f4 might be a clever thing
but well Bishop f4 I guess I because no
maybe yeah whites whites good quite a
number of options maybe not quite no
this would really change everything
Ganguly lost it's a shame too because I
thought he played so well 24 is on the
board that's the human base of f4 was
interesting though so right it's similar
to the variation we just played I think
white wants to play Bishop e3 and black
needs something right now to stop this
epic crunch against the black king
it's never good to see the f-pawn the
jeep on and the H pend gone from the
board with with your king stolen g8 the
funny thing too when you're a Kings
attacked like these beautiful pawns over
here don't mean that much right you know
let's stay here for a second and see
what Surya Ganguly does 38 seconds a lot
of time to figure it out Isis these our
positions are just terrible to have to
play especially when a White's next move
of Bishop e3 can be so simple you just
simply rook F eight rook F a little
closer to the king and maybe a few more
threats on the White King
that's recommend ought could be Bishop
e3 and then I try to survive the endgame
with Queen f5 should be 305
so it doesn't look like a pleasant onion
to survive though does it
well let's look first I don't you can't
take because it's some kind of Perpetual
is good right now I might be able to get
fancy and play f3 I'll give you the
Queen trade let's say the simple happens
I just want to play York C 1 and then
our C 7
I'll still play rixie seven
sure and now maybe I can start coming in
with my King King f1
rook b7 maybe actually I don't know
about this end game no it's gonna be a
drawing yeah that looks like a cat
you're on maybe I'm a move too slow with
this idea cuz if I could put my King on
g3 here then maybe there's something to
talk about let me just say this from
White's perspective maybe you have
reason maybe it's fine to take on f5 but
in general I think we want the Queen's
Own right so so so so more tricky I
think is Bishop III Queen f5 is the b71
maybe hanging no because the oh yeah
you're right you could maybe even think
about that so that's a true bummer if I
can take that point yeah I had some
trepidation I guess what about
that's a good question now this end game
is also terrible right but it's not it's
not necessarily totally totally lost
is there a queen bee three check they
have to worry about this should be for
Queen b3
I don't know if it actually does
something that's
right
what if I play I want to checkmate you
somehow but it's difficult these are all
so you know Oh Prince thinking you have
to bet I once I would just play Bishop
III let's see what happens but he's
thinking about it and one clever thing
is if you're if you just see Queen f5
coming and you prepare both Bishop III
and your next move then you can really
make Ganguly sweat because it's well
they should be threes the obvious move
after Queen f5 White has a lot of
different options he doesn't even do it
do you want he doesn't do it that's
probably why I'm not a super GM you know
and let's criticize me for a second
right now I just wanted the security
blanket situation of Bishop III where I
know nothing's gonna touch me and Oprah
is like no I can do that any time
and by doing rupee one I really make
Queen f5 much more difficult yeah and he
stinks I want to do it by the weeks away
some perpetual options right the King
knows at least one flight path through
the f1 square he still does it right
Queen a five on the board so so the idea
is if you snip snip root B 7 ayah Bishop
d4 and some hopes of counterplay right
so I said this is life Bishop e3 is kind
of like still necessary eventually and
in any case may be you know rupee one
looked real good but maybe Queen but we
have five is now you kind of a do have
to take it yeah oh this is maybe a bad
move I'm a little confused at this
decision white needs white needs a good
move here let's just say it that way so
it's funny first I criticize myself and
now my god I don't know
wait that's security blanket going
sometimes solid is better I liked I
thought from
maybe maybe white will take on f5 and
then take a slow approach just Bishop
III rook b4 and hold all the pawns
well what so so this is I guess this
would transpose but yes so this position
black plays B Phi well wait a second
this is not the same position well we
had let's let's update it here so they
did take on room takes f5 which I didn't
even know what White's supposed to do
there anymore so maybe just Bishop b3
and then eventually like if earth d5 rip
b4 I'll play King f1 let me say the
reason I'm skeptical now is like not
only do I have this pressure but if my
King gets to these light squares it's
gonna be a hard business and this rook
before is a passive piece yeah but I'll
replace that with my King right I want
to play King e2 and king d3 it's a
temporary thing
okay and now rippy one I want to change
pads okay that's just that's very mean
of you to do yeah so when you traded
Queens like the black King turned into
kind of a beast and let's say that this
pawn is on the wrong color because you
know black white just has the dark
squares and you lose all the the light
squares like as we saw with the King
coming so I mean before just to play
something like f4 and that's not really
what I want to do black immediately
played rook d5 sure about so let's think
about what he's saying he's saying rook
d7 Bishop takes there's a rookie for
threat takes
and we're saying there's no no nothing
special you can do let's try that again
so rook d5 you know I thought b5 was
fine but rip d5 is trying to end the
party immediately there's still this
trick before option it's past it so once
you play rugby for you know I could do
king f7 we can get the guy can get there
at a tempo early yeah and right on beat
also with b5
there's my you know I can liquidate with
I don't so I think rook be one now
Grigory next time just listen to me he
had you know Bishop III first alright
certainly but should be three offered
white more options in this type of
endgame right this was kind of very
forcing for white kind of cornered
himself okay I think he underestimated
just how dryish this endgame was gonna
be after Queen f5 quite a bit has
changed and the Brandon Jacobson game
all of a sudden things look different
Brandon listen to me buddy
your King was fine over there look at
this this rook and queen that went over
there ages ago to help the king move to
the move over now they're just like oh
my man come back goodness this is um I
all I know all they go and looking at
this is this is not what white want it
c3 is hanging a3 is hanging
I assume Knight c4 is Brandon's
intention here let's let's look at a
little bit let's recap
so this missed I'm gonna call this
misguided Brandon you're a genius but
this was misguided eight
snip there it comes that night remember
how terrible that night was before 394
Oh God this should see to a four oh no
Fe D its way to way way more complicated
than I wanted it to be bishop Beth oh my
god
and Oh Brandon man you know like we said
yesterday on the after he lost again
snake Suns he was complaining to me and
he had to like play we had to beat us
all down in bug house just to make
himself feel better but I was trying to
tell him you know I have I have a
lifetime of disappointment behind me of
chest disappointment you just got a
couple games Bren I don't know but
definitely this one might be adding to
the file adding adding to the
disappointment file
hey just fine let's look at night C 4
and C it looks real bad but let's just
see if there's any crushing body blow he
so the Queen's gotta move greens gotta
move
I guess simplest is maybe Queen f8 you
want to probably keep an eye on that a3
pawn it might be making that up that's
my first instinct sure that looks good
it's just this is just nasty isn't it
and fate there's threats along the F
file there's threats of Bishop f4
there's threats many many things for one
the c3 pawn it's still under attack and
let me say something obvious in this
position the fact that this Bishop is
the opposite color really so it's
opposite side castling which is going to
mean the initiative counts for more and
we have opposite color bishops which is
a added feature of the initiative
costing more so the pawns that Brandon
has you know are far less likely to be
meaningful simply because it's someone's
gonna get made it if someone's getting
made it and what I meant by the bishops
is that if black starts an initiative on
the dark squares white is simply down a
piece on the dark squares and this is
that this is a tender one this is a
tender one that's a tender one and
that's a tender so that's a lot of
tender yeah it's that's too much to kind
of keep control of I think
Black's pieces are already placed very
well for this attack White's pieces are
definitely not Brandon is so optimal
defensively this look at this position
that he's look let's just revisit Bishop
h6x clam beautiful move totally winning
now totally winning man okay let's move
on okay
let's see what happened with the count
hmm
he just pushed in Harry the H on him
move 40 and do I understand what's going
on here
it looks like the count is toast is that
right count is toast
right the cabbage is toast it that seems
like a normal saying ya know in terms of
a say yes in terms of the position right
it seems also true I tend to favor the
side with with the extra Queen so let's
look at what happens so this King f1
happened this is all time pressure so
all kind of all kinds of stuff
watch this unpleasant isn't it oh nice
move nice move well nice you know white
found a way for his King to not that
somehow escape but oh nice beautiful
play from black here oh yeah right away
my friend Oh
there there goes the Queen and it's so
he's fighting on but that looks totally
lost and I think the real thing was we
have we have two games here where the
where someone's facing his own opening
so the count is facing the groom felled
and sometimes this is a psychological
thing and we've seen a lot at the very
top level there's this thing where often
players are playing their opponents
opening against them the other game
happening this round is Savion is
playing it's the French and Safie and
also as a Armenian you have to play the
French at least once in a while so he
use a French player too so that's all
happening 94 on the board with Brandon
mm-hmm and let's go back to the top yeah
I did want to mention Jeffrey Zhang and
Dave Hal have drawn their game right so
that does leave the door a little bit
open for either Gawain Jones to win his
game to tie the leaders or Darius wits
is the other player in position to catch
the leaders potentially these are games
to keep an eye on sure and Gawain's game
one of the things I said was that black
would have a chance if he exchanged
Queens and so he did exchange Queens and
now not so easy yeah that a pawn has
made a little progress since black on
all the exchanges he wanted he wanted to
exchange Queens and he wanted to keep
the dark square bishop and keep his rook
on the board so he's it managed to have
all those things happen to me you were
talking about maybe the the redundancy
of having two rooks when you're typing
exchanges right like has managed to keep
that imbalance how that happened so you
know white played I thought one of the
games of the tournament here with all
these great Knight tricks
hi this is this is where we left it and
this was just beautiful chess queen d5
does he really have to exchange the
Queen's why not something simple just
Queen b6 because our rook is hanging on
b1 oh well that I guess is important
okay so that's an important resource for
black that was right when we left it
Queen d5 wonder maybe okay so we got
this thing maybe Queen takes e4 in
hindsight is a mistake it looks so
natural and so clever because you go
back and hit the c6 palm but the pawn on
e4 isn't a criminal you know so
something some other move that the keep
the Queen thought might be what we're
looking for here yeah because now the
Queen's come off no it's not so easy
oh yeah we can get a sit no I don't want
to put my rook there man no whites why
it's almost like repeating well he was
making control but I think I think this
is gonna be very hard to say that he's
making any progress because the yeah if
you don't take that take one of those
bishops off the board or a rook yeah so
he's just gonna be oh what a bummer
Oh Gawain I thought you had a great game
you know of course even when you when
you get an advantage like Liam Lee is is
a 2700 player and any resources you
offer him he's usually going to find
this well it's funny it was Glenn who
found all the resource yeah and here
it's like he tricked himself like what
we both thought this was an ingenious
trick to win the pawn but in fact what
it does is it allows black to get the
Queen's off and then the black King
position is not a problem any rare oh
you were doing so good so close and how
is Darius doing in his game yeah that's
look last time Sam was putting the real
heat on so let's go where we stopped
last time which was rook c6 is how I
remember it
somewhere river came in to c7 c7 yeah
rook c7 there we go
rook e8 and sanch temp said yep so at
least Titan at least I know where Sam's
coming from so is it totally winning or
is it just clear advantage it seems like
you should be winning so by far the best
trips are superior here to Black's
pieces but I guess the question is
obviously the black king or the white
king can't escape right now and if he
does want to escape it looks like you
have to maybe fix one of blacks doubled
pawns there was something like f3 right
so the the idea blacks idea is to grip
all the light squares and a very cruel
it and throw away and then say that by
keeping the King out we will hold this
game now we're just beginning is I think
the Kings gonna have a couple shots to
get out but this is at least clever
so someday I guess we're expecting to
see maybe a ch3 I don't really see any
other way to break this kind of bind on
the light squares but as soon as you
play a ch3 black of course can respond
by taking and then just playing G for
for a second time well and Marin my too
that when we have the bishop here he had
the option right now of playing a ch3 so
the but the problem though is like let's
say this happens King still not getting
out yeah G for the second time is
problematic so maybe he's putting
pressure on the d5 apartment and this is
this is his new plan maybe try to find
some situation where you can threaten to
take that that night off of f6 and be
threatening that d5 I want to go back to
this for a second it seems like White's
gotta be winning this without that much
grief for example if you really so rook
c7 c8 is arguably dogmatic because the
rook is a beautiful piece there our rook
is and we're trading it off with the
notion that that endgame should be
winning for us and I get it it feels
like a safe thing to do and yadda yadda
but here we have so many moves we could
play h3 now maybe even g6 and Bishop e6
is gonna play rook c8 but it's
definitely a thought to play Bishop d6
so this is maybe not the best it's funny
you know do we infinity to talk to Sam
to ask him if he thought this is totally
winning and honestly it wouldn't
surprise me if White's able to find a
way here
but we need we need a we need something
here this Bishop d7 who I think is
telegraphing the idea of maybe he's
gonna play this should be for next and
then if something like King f7 simply
Bishop d6 and Bishop e5 and this might
force the black bishop to either go to
c4 or f3 which is not the ideal squares
I think on both accounts I think the
other thing we want to do is we'd like
to force him to play b5 yeah it's
totally possible to throw that in as
well right
Bishop d6 and then may be thrown at
Bishop c7 and then Bishop e5 and and
then if we put say the bishop on c6
after that then the the his light square
bishop will have even less moves yeah I
think this is a great plan I think Sam
in my opinion is just targeting you know
the weakness is that that he can with
the two bishops and then if the pieces
for black get distracted over the Queen
side then that's what's gonna let that
King out I don't you know looking at it
it really feels like blacks got a nice
grip okay so I'll play my move Bishop b4
oh so first question is king e4 well
there should be there should be seven I
think right
there's something to worry about
especially with that pawn still and be
six actually it could be a problem with
with Bishop III check possibly coming to
discover the king
the only thing is this spot isn't such a
big deal it's only for that you know
double yeah you could take it and then
do your age 3 thing yeah anyways this
would be my first instinct fish again
798
so I think I can take on g5 this is
indirectly defending a defending d4 okay
my bishops a little stuck I guess I'll
go to c6 now
I'm just moving I'm just kidding the
night active I'm not doing anything
special right oh yeah the night
arresting I'll play b3 b3 95 yeah take
your points but maybe I can play Bishop
EA and force you to capture my my pawn I
guess you might play King f3 I didn't
consider that well listen what's him did
he
so king after king f5 he played check to
the miserable King and this is this is I
think good we're just gonna make sure
that the King know what don't let him
into you poor don't do it there's no
rush with with these ideas I guess is
ready saying as long as the king is
stuck on a place like g6 you can take
your time so he went back he trusted Sam
and Sam yeah needs to let's let's
imagine so we want to do the bishop
before he does do bishop before no I
think we're aiming for like a Zook swung
in a lot of positions so like Bishop d6
tap the tap the pond and then come back
and say that this guy can't move that
the knight
well maybe then I can move is part of
the problem but it doesn't have a lot of
squares to move to this is to me this is
an interesting part part of chess is the
kind of limited geometry where there's
not many pieces left but somehow it's
still difficult to get that Bishop onto
the diagonal that you wanted on I think
getting b5 is a real bummer for him for
example on that h3 variation if I come
here and then back and then
and then I'm touching this coconut right
maybe maybe I got a little
something-something
you dare touch my coconuts Jessie yeah
okay so yeah that's gonna be ongoing for
Gawain let's just witness Gawain here
wait he did he did he accomplish
anything they're probably know I
definitely switch sides of the board
this rook is immolated and it related
that stuff okay let's roll through some
of our other games here let's look at
Sam seve on we had the big question of
how if and how he can make progress the
king retreated from his perch on f4 put
the rook on f4 so now notice the king
went back so that the black rook can't
come in and white goes back now what
what if anything is White's Thrym but
this looks nearly had identical to the
position where you're at but I guess
rook h4 is his idea right good so let's
play rook h5 can i play wreckage for
anyways maybe oh good move yeah good
that looks yeah I think that would just
be winning so you look G for it is an
idea to keep the rock out
I think the danger there might come
after Bishop d1 and if you do capture my
rook I might take with the Jeep on and
then my king can run from g3 to h4 and
then to h5 and then then I can really
make some threats
you seem to have trepidation I'm just
thinking about how I'm wondering like so
let's imagine this rook gets in right
it's definitely a bonus but it looks
like a big deal sure cuz you you got all
kinds of things to touch once you get in
there imagine if I could jump over that
F pawn and go to f6 that would be an
accomplishment Wow I mention also in
this B group the two leaders Oprah and
Ganguly have officially drawn their game
you see they're the kings in the center
Ganguly escaped that was a big a big one
for Ganguly a lot of danger there
definitely and I guess our critical
moment was when Oprah and didn't listen
to me and didn't do the security blanket
move but it'd be three and it's dead
played would be one where the rook was
it looks so active on b1 but after this
all goes down you still have to play
Bishop e3 and I thought b5 was drawing
as well but this was the attempt to
immediately oh this was his trick was it
good you can imagine how white at least
went for this as an idea it's a pretty
clever idea there are some chances here
definitely but maybe enough black simply
gets the pawn down the board
great game great save by Ganguly
definitely and so that'll mean Ganguly
is still at the top yeah right because
he and he and Oprah actually both of
them yeah so they maintain their lead
over the rest of the field
nobody pulling ahead of the other one
and so what do we what do we think let's
take a look and at maybe the the
standings
coming out of this round in the a group
and let's see where we think everybody
is going to stand well maybe we can take
a look at all of the remaining games
here and make some predictions for what
we think is going to okay so let's say
with Brandon mm-hm
your move by the way you you get to win
that prize yeah it just seems like the
perfect square for the Queen and queen
g4 was just playing
no g4 okay wait I need to understand
this so Queen f8
obviously this is a problem right queen
g4 is saying it's not a problem
alright maybe there's nothing we could
do about it I got it I don't understand
maybe I don't need to understand but
Queen g4 a free pond and an important
pawn and my Knights closer to your king
you know what one really terrible bummer
two is if I get in Knight c3 mm-hmm then
Bishop f4 is essentially a made threat
yeah so i'm queen g4 let's just see what
if the kid has any thoughts after Knight
I mean he's spent quite a bit of time on
this move so you have to imagine he has
an idea here maybe he's playing I don't
know what he's thinking
I mean he might already be just really
it might be dead it might be dead Oh
Brandon I'm sorry buddy we're gonna I'll
play bughouse with you tonight that can
beat me it's fine
some stress relief so but maybe the kid
is very clever so he might have some
idea I wouldn't put it past the idea
that we're not seeing here okay so it's
some way that you're gonna sack on f-for
me this looks bizarre but just hear me
out so how about king d - no I can't do
that okay so we're waiting on that it
looks like our production is that he is
toast yeah I would I would agree and the
only other game remaining in the C group
is the couch is the count which of
course he seems to be missing the lady
missing the lady the very important lady
and I think in general even without the
beep on this would probably be loss yeah
well it seems like way to split to have
any kind of a fortress here and of
course the b-pawn is the icing on the
cake right so I think so and the counts
been having a really hard time n't and I
empathize with him I feel like you know
this is the count I think is a little
bit better than me but I can imagine
going this tournament happiness
same kind of result okay Samuel we're
gonna say we like his chances yeah we're
kind of I'm rooting for the white player
here by the way
I think anyone who plays that win a war
deserves death so this is a fitting end
if it's how it's gonna go
and then we have Shanklin let's take one
more look at shaker I he got him to move
let's just let's just go in here for a
second got that beep on/off of b6 that's
thought got to be you know I created in
that movement and now we're gonna cruise
back this way keeping that night under
control
although the d6 square seems open it's
just that King how do you get that king
to play let's let's look at 96 cuz
that's what he's looking at here so 96
do you play b3 yeah
well then of my bishops Han oh well that
too but Bishop d7 oh that's kind of
here's so the one question is well
that's winning yeah okay so Bishop d7 so
Bishop d7 is the answer tonight classics
now can I do 6 Bishop d7 kingi 7 Bishop
c6 this is right in which case you know
we're just kind of moving around and
around and around right and we've
accomplished our first sometimes you
read old Russian books and they give you
like some deep algorithm how to move how
to win an endgame and they'll be like
step 1 make him move the b-pawn step 2
your king step 3 there will be a trick
in the endgame okay so you did play he's
still waiting so I don't know I like
Sam's chances yeah if anyone wins it's
definitely Sam and then the final game I
got portable Jones Horde only although
not too poor it looks like I'll
definitely be able to hold a draw in a
matter way oh no it's never that I don't
think that's ever been down yet is that
the guy who deserved more that sequence
of moves he deserves there's a lot I
think a lot of credit at least if not
the full point is he perhaps planning to
do some kind of a trick
I guess it doesn't work here I was
having visions of playing Bishop takes a
three and then taking somehow with rook
d2 you know setting up some kind of
skier with the bishops but it looks like
it's a ways away because there's always
some intermediate check right but I'm
sure he's drew that's the kind of thing
he's dreaming about yeah so yeah we're
gonna be back day after tomorrow
yeah and let's take a look at our final
standings for today and then we'll give
you our final thoughts on the tournament
thus far in the a group Geoffrey and
David did draw their game preserving
their lead Colleen Jones had some
chances today but was not able to really
prove too much against Liam Lee and of
course Sam Franklin is trying his
hardest to pull out a victory here to
try and start the the climb back up to
the top of the leaderboard and over in
the B group Sri Ganguly has drawn his
game against Gregorio proned the the
co-leaders and Hove honest caboose Ian
drew against Daniel Freedman pretty
early on today the game we're waiting on
is Sam Sabean playing against Igor
Kovalenko if Sam can pull that off he
starts to chip away at that lead that
Ganguly and Oprah and have had built up
and over in the C group
archers and Ike Suns still the man of
the day preserving his lead with the
draw today and there are some some shake
ups going on though between the the four
followers
it looks like else Shaun might be able
to pull it off against Brandon Jacobs oh
definitely a tough position for him
there with his king being a bit weak and
our own poco bian is simply in a winning
endgame with a beep on and a queen
against a rook and a knight and so we
expect Aram and maybe even all Shaun to
pull out a win here closing the gap a
little bit against archers Naik Suns
certainly an interesting finish to the
first half of this tournament a lot to
look forward to in the second half with
you know every section still fully up in
the air as the players move into their
second round of playing everyone in the
event any final thoughts on today's
games Jesse anything interesting left to
say I want to predict that the rest day
doesn't make you feel that risk
and that as we move through in this
brutal tournament people will take more
chances and they're not necessarily
going to be rational chances when you're
a little tired you're gonna do more
provocative weird stuff and I think
that's what we're gonna see in the
second half and so whoever can keep
their wits it's gonna have a better
chance here right well there's certainly
a lot of action left at the summer chess
classic but we do have more exciting
events to follow events such as the
Croatia leg the crucial leg of the grand
chest or all of the regulars will be
there the world's best battling it out
you can join us for coverage from June
26 through July 8 and following that
almost immediately we have the US Junior
Championship the US girls junior
championship and for the first time ever
the u.s. Senior Championship so those
players over 50 will get a chance to
come back in the spotlight and battle it
out with some of their peers from from
back in the day of course you can join
us here on Monday for more coverage of
the summer chess classic and with that
in mind I think that's it for today
thank you all for joining us you can
stay tuned
following the games live on us chess
Transcom if you want to see how the rest
of these shake out and I will see you
next time here with Jessie cry
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
[Music]
you
[Music]
you